[Musique]
elle a une bruxelles passe au crible le
vaccin foot nick v une délégation
d'experts de l'agencé européenne du
médicament arrive en russie de vaccin
est en cours de validation il s'agit
d'examiner ces composants et les
capacités production si certains pays
attendent le feu vert du régulateur
d'autres comme l'autriche dernièrement
ou décidé de l'utiliser c'est le cas
déjà de 50 pays à travers le monde
en inde la situation se dégrade le pays
fait face à une deuxième vague très
violente d'un fiction comique 19 les
autorités roccon fine certaines régions
et veulent accélérer la vaccination de
la population conséquence le deuxième
producteur de vaccins anti qu'ovide au
monde stop toute exportation
une situation qui inquiète les nations
unies
[Musique]
et puis veille des présidentielles au
bénin et au tchad où l'on s'apprête à
voter ce dimanche dans ces deux pays les
présidents sortants sont candidats au
bénin patrice talon vise un deuxième
mandat au tchad idriss deby itno un
allié des occidentaux dans la lutte
antiterroriste lui en brigue un sixième
leur pays ont connu des troubles avant
les scrutins les manifestations au bénin
ont fait deux morts
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur un rt france une
délégation d'experts de l'agencé
européenne du médicament arrive
aujourd'hui en russie une visite d'une à
deux semaines pour examiner les données
de spoutnik v le régulateur européen
doit donner son autorisation pour son
utilisation mais certains états membres
n'ont pas attendu le feu vert il utilise
déjà et d'autres en ont précommandé des
millions de doses on voit cela avec
pierre pissavy yvernault attendre l'aval
de l'agencé européenne des médicaments
avant de se tourner vers le spoutnik v
voilà ce qui semble être la stratégie de
l'union européenne
mais depuis quelques semaines des
régions au coeur des 27 ne veulent plus
attendre et c'est le cas de la bavière
en allemagne hollande annonce avoir
négocié un contrat préliminaire en vue
de recevoir deux millions et demi de
doses du vaccin russe
même constat en espagne la région de
madrid annonce avoir négocié avec moscou
en déplacement au sénégal le chef du
gouvernement a tenu à rappeler la
stratégie espagnole
nous allons poursuivre la vaccination
avec astrazeneca à partir de 60 ans
6 pout nick est homologué par le m a
bien entendu nous pourront inclure ce
vaccin dans le portefeuille des vaccins
mais il faut que ce vaccin soit
homologué cela n'a pas encore été le cas
nombre de l'union européenne la
slovaquie a passé commande auprès de
moscou est réceptionné une partie des
doses dès le mois dernier
de son côté le petit état de saint-marin
utilise pique nique v depuis début mars
le pays non membres de l'union
européenne espère ainsi pallier les
retards de livraison des vaccins
occidentaux le but atteindre rapidement
l'immunité collective
aujourd'hui près d'un tiers de la
population est vaccinée et la cadence
devrait dans les jours à venir
s'accélérer l'objectif est d'atteindre
l'immunité collective d'ici la fin du
mois de mai donc l'objectif est de
concentrer toutes nos ressources puisque
nous avons vu qu'avec le variant
britannique
la contagion est élevé elle l'est aussi
chez nous évidemment les effets de la
vaccination sont visibles puisque l'âge
moyen des personnes infectées a baissé
mais l'objectif est de conclure la
campagne de vaccination avant la fin du
mois de mai en europe spoutnik v fait
l'objet d'une procédure par l' agence
européenne des médicaments depuis le 4
mars dernier il a fallu plus d'un mois
pour accréditer les sérums fader et
moderna et près de quatre mois pour
l'astra zeneca concernant spoutnik v des
conclusions pourraient être rendues
d'ici la fin du mois de juin prochain
astrazeneca de nouveau en retard sur la
moitié de ses livraisons prévues cette
semaine à l'union européenne ce n'est
pas la première fois tout cela sur fond
de polémique sur ces possibles effets
secondaires après des cas de thrombose
la france enregistré même quatre décès
la haute autorité de santé recommande
désormais à ceux qui en ont déjà reçu
une première dose de se faire injecter
une seconde
cette fois avec pfizer ou modern art par
ailleurs elle préconise aux régions les
plus touchées par le variant sud
africains de ne pas utiliser le forum
astrazeneca les précisions c'est avec
amaya souplesse des voix discordantes
autour du vaccin astrazeneca lui même
concerné olivier vers ans l'a annoncé ce
vendredi
les personnes ayant reçu leur première
injection du vaccin suède aux
britanniques pourront recevoir leur
deuxième dose d'un autre vaccin à m
il est tout à fait cohérent de dire on
ne recommande pas le vaccin astrazeneca
au moins de 55 ans en attendant d'en
savoir plus
et donc si vous allez reçu une première
injection et que vous avez moins de 55
ans on va vous proposer un autre vaccin
à 12 semaines après la première
injection vous recevrez une injection
d'un vaccin arn messager un avis que
rejoint également la haute autorité de
santé qui jugent cette pratique
fréquente dans la lutte d'autres
maladies comme ebola ce vendredi
l'institution a confirmé qu utiliser
deux vaccins combinés et largement
préconisé une solution qui concerne plus
de cinq cent mille personnes en france
la décision a finalement été
relativement simple
on sait qu'une seule dose de vaccin
n'est pas suffisante pour assurer une
immunité au long cours contre la copie
19 il fallait donc prendre une décision
sur le vaccin administré pour la
deuxième dose
il a donc été décidé d'utiliser un
vaccin arn on sait que ça marche très
bien et cela donne des réponses
immunitaires qui sont plus importantes
que lorsqu'on utilise deux fois le même
vaccin mais l'organisation mondiale de
la santé n'est pas du même avis tant que
les données ne sont pas suffisamment
exploitées le changement de vaccins
entre deux doses n'est pas recommandé il
n'y a pas de données adéquates pour dire
si c'est quelque chose qui peut être
fait l'interchangeabilité des vaccins
n'est pas quelque chose qu'on peut
recommander à ce stade autorisé le 2
février dernier le vaccin astrazeneca a
été dans un premier temps à administrer
aux plus de 65 ans pour être élargie
ensuite à toute la population
après les décès consécutive suite à des
cas de thrombose de plusieurs personnes
ayant reçu ce vaccin
il a été momentanément suspendue en
france et dans plusieurs pays d'europe
pour en évaluer les risques en france
depuis le 19 mars dernier
il est uniquement administré aux plus de
55 ans la france qui totalisent plus de
10 millions de primo vacciner la
campagne s'accélère pas assez rapidement
pour certains et surtout pas de façon
assez claire c'est la vie en tout cas de
pascal saurait les médecins généralistes
en saône et loire on l'écouté
concrètement on est perplexe que ce soit
la population que ce soit les médecins
on nous annonce des choses complètement
contradictoire entre l'achat laisse l'om
s j'avoue que je sais plus quoi dire à
mes patients je leur dis que je leur
proposais le vaccin sera zeneca s'il
souhaite le faire au fait s'il veulent
pas le faire on ne le fait pas j'avoue
qu'on a un manque de communication
claire là dessus et les gens plus
confiance et c'est vraiment très
compliqué on a une situation qui est
extrêmement complexe et on n'a pas
d'outils pour donner des réponses
claires aux patients il ya deux
problèmes déjà le problème c'est de
compatibilité des vaccins entre eux cela
on le sait il ya aucun problème
ça fait depuis pasteur depuis la
multiplication des vaccins on sait très
bien que les vaccins peuvent se faire
tous en même temps il n'y a pas de
problème par contre qu'est ce qu'il en
est de l'efficacité
on nous parle du vaccin contre le vih or
à prendre du contraire le vaccin contre
le vih il expérimental on nous parle de
technique de prix et de prime boosting
d'immunité voilà on est expérimental on
ne sait pas est ce qu'on peut se
permettre d'être expérimental avec une
épidémie de kobe dans france qui flambe
avec des nombres de cas explosif avec
des entrées en réanimation explosive
est-ce qu'on tousse permettent d'être
expérimental entre l agence européenne
des médicaments n'enquête pas seulement
sur les cas de thrombose liés au vaccin
astrazeneca mais aussi à celui de
johnson & johnson le vaccin du
laboratoire américain est autorisée au
sein de l'union européenne n'est pas
encore utilisée pour l'instant il n'y a
aucun lien établi à ce stade selon le
régulateur américain la fda est au
courant d'informations aux états unis
sur des événements thromboemboliques
graves parfois associée à une
thrombopénie qui se sont produits j'ai
quelques individus après avoir reçu le
vaccin contre le coc vite 19,2 en scène
pour le moment nous n'avons pas trouvé
de lien de causalité avec la vaccination
et nous continuons notre enquête et
évaluation de ces cas
en faire le point maintenant sur la
situation en inde qui fait face à une
deuxième vague de coronavirus
foudroyante
à partir de ce samedi bombay et sa
région se confinent les week-ends et ce
jusqu'à la fin du mois d'avril une mise
sous cloche qui concerne 125 millions
d'indiens une décision motivée par les
pénuries de vaccins qui touche l'état du
maharashtra à et plusieurs autres
régions du pays avec des conséquences
qui pourraient bien dépasser ses
frontières
le point avec maxime à berne à bombay
dans les centres de vaccination les
files d'attentes sont quasi inexistantes
l'un des premiers producteurs de vaccins
au monde et sa capitale économique n'ont
pourtant pas fini avec leurs campagnes
de vaccination
bien au contraire à ce jour seuls 94
millions de doses de vaccin anti
qu'ovide ont été administrées dans le
pays pour une population de 1,3 milliard
d'habitants soit moins d'un pour cent de
la population vaccinée et aujourd'hui
les doses manque suis venu ici pour me
faire vacciner mais ils m'ont dit qu'ils
n'avaient pas de stock alors je suis
rentré chez moi ils m'ont demandé de
revenir demain aujourd'hui nous sommes
allés au bureau de par l bmc ils nous
ont demandé de revenir dans trois quatre
jours pour récupérer le stock de vaccins
car il n'avait pas de stock disponible
aujourd'hui l'état du maharashtra où se
trouve bombay a même pris la décision
d'arrêter de vacciner ce vendredi dans
le poumon économique du pays
dès jeudi les 72 établissements privés
chargés d'administrer les doses étaient
arrivés au bout de leurs stocks
cette situation catastrophique couplée
aux plus de 120 mille nouveaux cas
enregistrés en 24 heures un record pour
le pays a poussé bombay son état se
confiner depuis ce samedi et durant tout
le mois d'avril
les magasins seront donc fermés chaque
week end et les 125 millions d'habitants
priés de rester chez eux
il devrait y avoir les deux le
confinement et la possibilité pour les
gens de gérer leurs affaires
il n'y a pas d'activité nous devrions au
moins être capable de gagner un peu
d'argent pour faire face à nos dépenses
on a des enfants et des familles
on devrait être au moins capables de les
nourrir cette mise sous cloche la
première depuis le confinement nationale
de mars 2020 risque d'accroître un peu
plus les fortes inégalités dans l'état
le plus riche d'inde en juin dernier
la banque mondiale avait estimé à 12
millions le nombre d'indiens tomber dans
une situation d'extrême pauvreté à cause
de ce confinement généraliser les
projections des nations unies
envisageait que 104 millions d'autres
indiens passeraient sous le seuil de
pauvreté portant à 920 millions le
nombre d'habitants très vulnérable soit
près de 70% de la population indienne la
situation en inde pourrait aussi avoir
des répercussions sur d'autres pays à
revenus faibles piliers du programme
onusien kovacs depuis le début de la
crise l'inde a exporté 64 millions de
doses vers l'afrique l'asie du sud ou
encore le brésil désormais outre les
mesures restrictives le pays freinent
voir stop toute exportation de vaccins
vers l'étranger pour donner la priorité
à sa population
on le voit le nombre d'opca a dû à des
variants ne cesse de croître à il
progresse vite surtout au brésil que
certains surnomment lusine à variant sur
place la catastrophe sanitaire et d'une
rare ampleur djair bolson arrow est
pointé du doigt pour avoir minimisé la
crise le président est d'ailleurs visé
par une enquête parlementaire félix ul
comme un symbole des paradoxes brésilien
depuis hier les plages de rio sont à
nouveau fréquenter alors que le pays est
devenu l'épicentre mondial de l'épidémie
les autorités de la ville ont en effet
décidé de lever largement les
restrictions qui pesé sur les
restaurants les bars et les boutiques
après deux semaines de confinement
partiel en groupe nous avons une courbe
qui descend qui nous donne une vision
plus optimiste
ces mesures restrictives ont eu un effet
et on fonctionnait pourtant si certains
indicateurs vont dans le bon sens le
nombre de morts continue de progresser
cette semaine en moyenne 4000 personnes
sont décédées chaque jour du comice 19
faisant du brésil le pays le plus
endeuillé du monde après les états unis
une situation qui place les hôpitaux au
bord de la rupture
nous ne pouvons pas dormir parce que
nous ne savons pas si nous aurons les
conditions pour nous occuper des
patients si nous aurons des médicaments
de l'oxygène les conditions pour
s'occuper correctement des patients
aujourd'hui nous les avons aimé 6 et 4
continue à augmenter
à un moment donné ce sera le chaos il
n'y a pas d'autre solution
de son côté le président jaillir bodson
arrow refusent tout changement de
stratégie et remet systématiquement
cause les restrictions prises par les
gouverneurs n'a été
il n'y aura pas de confinement nationale
certains osent dire que l'armée devrait
aider certains gouverneurs dans leurs
mesures restrictives
notre armée brésilienne ne descendra pas
dans la rue pour garder les gens à
l'intérieur de leur maison
une commission d' enquête parlementaire
sur la gestion de la pandémie a
d'ailleurs été créé à la demande d'un
juge de la cour suprême
dans le même temps la vaccination n'a
toujours pas décollé dans le pays - 2 3
% des brésiliens ont pour le moment été
vaccinées une situation qui inquiète une
partie de la population
nous n'avons pas un gouvernement qui
agit comme il devrait le faire donc la
tendance est toujours à l'aggravation
parce que 4000 personnes qui meurent par
jour c'est beaucoup c'est vraiment dur
[Musique]
c'est inquiétant ça nous inquiète tous
j'ai des enfants j'ai des petits enfants
donc on s'inquiète
et s'il n'y a pas de vaccination c'est
pire c'est vraiment sérieux je pense
qu'ils devraient tous fermés faire un
vrai compliment
le président le gouverneur s'ils
s'unissent notre vaccination s'améliora
beaucoup parce que si vous comparez avec
les autres pays du monde
je pense que nous vaccinons rapidement
mais nous avons une grande population
le brésil est désormais décrit par les
experts comme une gigantesque usine à
variant mettant en péril la lutte contre
l'épidémie dans la région et dans le
reste du monde
l'institut focus équivalent local du
pasteur france est ainsi identifié près
de 92 nouvelle souche du coronavirus
dans le pays
le tchad pays enclavé du sahel se
prépare avant le scrutin présidentiel de
demain les militaires vote aujourd'hui
par anticipation afin d'assurer la
sécurité du scrutin
réélection sans suspense avec un immense
favori le président sortant idriss deby
itno à la tête du pays depuis 30 ans il
est réputé pour être un contributeur de
poids dans la guerre contre les
djihadistes un allié de la france à la
capitale du pays djamena abrite le
commandement de l'opération française
barkan au sahel
mais son pouvoir laisse peu de place à
l'opposition qui peine à s'organiser
il interdit ces rassemblements résultat
une grande partie de cette opposition
paul cote le scrutin élections a
également demain au bénin dans un
contexte difficile
le président sortant patrice talon a
tenu un dernier grand meeting pour
mobiliser ses partisans est la campagne
électorale elle a été marquée par des
violences dans le nord et le centre du
pays l'armée est intervenue jeudi pour
mettre fin au blocage des routes
organisé par des manifestantes et ses
barrages ont fortement retardé le
déploiement par camion du matériel
électoral les affrontements entre forces
de l'ordre et protestataires ont fait au
moins deux morts et cinq blessés
soutenant le président talent nous
allons le soutenir jusqu'à date dernière
souffle parce que c'est un président
opère depuis l'indépendance n'avons pas
vu un président qui a pu tenir le pays
de la sorte la corruption est banni nous
avons l'administration match ça la
corruption la sécurité aux points
dans des bulles en nord qui est très
bien organisé il ya une transition ou le
paiement et de plus fréquents et des
merveilles est la raison pour laquelle
est une question de point de vue de
garder le bilan du fener patate à la
libye vous savez tout dépend politique
sans surprise la réaction hadj et goûter
du président ismaël omar guelleh hier
avec 98 58 % des voix selon des
résultats officiels provisoires
le président va entamer son cinquième et
dernier mandat conformément en tout cas
à la constitution dans les rues de la
capitale certains saluent sa réélection
d'autres elle dénonce des dérives
puis c'est une bonne nouvelle pour nous
et pour la république des outils et pour
la paix aussi toujours il se calait la
jeunesse les femmes les femmes au
premier lieu les femmes un tunnel sans
autorité ras du boutis c'est ce qui
compte pour nous on est là on va rentrer
50 des difficultés plus qu'avant 50 des
difficultés 52 sont au chômage
52 des fraudes cinq ans combat est très
par terre
tu vois le pays il est
comment dirais-je il est sous la
pression de ce roi c'est pas un
président trois ans lire en brouille les
cartes sur fond de dialogue pour sauver
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien signé
en 2015 le pays modernise son complexe
nucléaire de natanz dans le centre est
le président hassan rohani yao
inaugurait 163 centrifugeuses certaines
ont été mises en service d'autres juste
tester et cela s'est passé viennent
cérémonie en visio conférence
retransmise par la télévision d'état
le pacte paraphé en 2015 interdit à
l'iran pourtant d'utiliser ces
installations en ce moment les
signataires de l'accord de vienne
discute avec la république islamique et
washington sur la façon d'y réintégrer
les etats-unis sortis en 2018 des
pourparlers tendu et l'iran demande la
levée des sanctions américaines des
états unis plus d'efforts
les négociateurs américains ont avancé
une idée très sérieuse et montrer une
réelle intention de recommencer à
respecter l'accord si l'iran s'y
conforment à nouveau nous avons vu
certains signes mais certainement pas
assez est la question est de savoir si
l'iran à la volonté de choisir la même
approche pragmatique que celle des états
unis pour se conformer de nouveau à ses
obligations prévues par l'accord
écoutez l'analyse de gérard des pierres
et les fondateurs du web magazine le
monde décrypté
il s'agit là d'un jeu de tactique de
pression n'est ce pas de part et d'autre
de la table à vous avez donc les
iraniens qui viennent de faire cette
annonce il y avait eu d'autre part à des
attaques sur des sites saoudien a donc
de la part des outils ge au yémen
soutenu par téhéran
donc vous avez un jeu n'est ce pas de
pression vis-à-vis de l'autre camp
occidental à qui lui même mais des
pressions aussi sur terre en oublions
pas à les attaques qui ont eu lieu en
iran sur des installations industrielles
et même nucléaire à la tâche et aussi
les
mination d'un haut responsable du
département de la défense fakhrizadeh et
au mois deux mois de novembre donc il y
à des pressions et d'autres pas chaque
parti dit ce n'est pas à moi de faire le
premier pas c'est à vous de le faire
l'émissaire de l'onu pour la birmanie a
entamé hier en thaïlande une tournée
diplomatique en asie objectif favoriser
une solution régionale à la crise birman
de son côté l'ambassadeur birman à l'onu
limogé par la junte mais toujours en
fonction a imploré la communauté
internationale je cite de passer à
l'action ils réclament une zone
d'exclusion aérienne pour contrer les
raids contre les minorités à des
sanctions contre la junte et un embargo
sur les armes
avec l'intensification de la répression
et des milliers de civils s'exile depuis
le coup d'état du 1er février dernier
qui a renversé l'ex chef de gouvernement
au sein de sotchi plus de 600 civils ont
été tués et près de 3000 personnes
arrêtées certains jours nous avons dû
nous faufiler entre les gaz lacrymogènes
et les bombes fumigènes
bien que nous ayons manifester
pacifiquement nous avons dû fuir à cause
de la répression violente
nous savons que si nous étions arrêtés
les forces de sécurité ne nous
laisserait pas envie elle nous tueraient
alors nous avons dû nous enfuir
nous ne pouvons compter que sur les
groupes armés ethnique après que la
junte militaire a lancé des mandats
d'arrêt contre les fonctionnaires
impliqués dans le mouvement de
désobéissance civile
la confiance pourrait être établi entre
les fonctionnaires et les groupes armés
ethnique
ils nous aident et ils sont gentils nous
nous sentons en sécurité ici depuis
qu'ils ont commencé à se ranger de notre
côté nous leur avons dit demander tout
ce que nous pouvons faire pour vous
aider
nous sommes prêts à vous aider et du
côté de la junte le discours hausse
durci sortie médiatique hier du
porte-parole de l'armée birmane au sujet
de la grève nationale actuellement en
cours dans le pays et la compare je cite
à un génocide
aujourd'hui les hôpitaux publics ne
peuvent plus fonctionner car les agents
de santé ne respectent pas leur éthique
à l'hôpital public de rangoun
500 personnes mourraient en moyenne par
mois alors maintenant combien ça peut
être à l'échelle nationale on tue des
gens de sang froid
j'aimerais dire qu'il s'agit d'un
génocide ça ne s'appelle pas un génocide
qu'est ce que c'est retour en france
maintenant avec ces plaintes concernant
le dossier du chlordécone un insecticide
interdit sur le territoire en 1990
plusieurs association martiniquaise et
guadeloupéenne ont porté plainte mais ce
procès pourrait aboutir à un non lieu en
raison de la prescription des faits les
explications c'est avec estelle farges
se dirige-t-on vers un non-lieu dans le
scandale du chlordécone c'est en tout
cas ce que laissent penser les
déclarations du procureur de la
république rémy est dans la sphère des
empoisonnements au chlordécone qui ont
secoué la martinique et la guadeloupe
les problèmes de prescription existait
pour l'essentiel dès le dépôt des
plaintes il était nécessaire que la
justice pénale avec les moyens
d'investigation importants dont elle
dispose
contribuer avec d'autres à faire la
lumière sur les raisons de l'utilisation
du chlordécone en guadeloupe et en
martinique
le chlordécone est un insecticide
utilisé dans les champs de bananier
martiniquais et guadeloupéens entre 1972
et 1993 pour éliminer un insecte le
charançon du bananier en 1979 l' oms
place le chlordécone comme cancérigènes
possibles
plus de dix ans après en 1990 son
utilisation est interdite en france mais
en guadeloupe et en martinique elle va
se poursuivre jusqu'en 1993 notamment
grâce à des dérogations ministériel
résultat selon santé publique france
plus de 90% de la population adulte sur
ces 2 il est contaminé par le
chlordécone et on observe un taux
d'incidence du cancer de la prostate
parmi les plus élevés au monde en 2019
une commission d' enquête parlementaire
publié un rapport
il pointe la responsabilité de l'état
dans ce qui est qualifié de désastre
sanitaire et environnementale l'état a
fait subir des risques inconsidérés au
vu des connaissances scientifiques de
l'époque aux populations et aux
territoires de guadeloupe et de
martinique le maintien de la production
bananière a trop souvent pris le pas sur
la sauvegarde de la santé publique
et de l'environnement en 2006 trois
plaintes sont déposées par des
associations martiniquaise et
guadeloupéenne pour empoisonnement mise
en danger de la vie d'autrui et
administration de substances nuisibles
mais les faits dénoncés pour la plupart
étaient déjà prescrits selon la
législation de l'époque les délais de
prescription à l'aide trois ans pour les
délits à 10 pour les crimes
le dossier est malgré tout instruit
depuis 14 ans par le pôle santé publique
du tribunal judiciaire de paris
deux avocats de l'association médicale
de sauvegarde de l'environnement et de
la santé ont annoncé avoir déposé un
mémoire auprès des juges afin de
contester la question de la prescription
ils ont aussi indiqué vouloir déposer
plainte contre plusieurs anciens
ministres devant la cour de la justice
de la république pour avoir prolongé
l'autorisation d'utilisation du
chlordécone les avocats qui comptent
aussi sur la pression de la population
concernée par ce scandale
fin février cinq à dix mille personnes
se sont mobilisées dans les rues de fort
de france contre cette possible
prescription de nouveaux rassemblements
étaient organisés ce week end et c'est
la fin de ce journal merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi dans 30 minutes on va se
retrouver pour une nouvelle édition
reste avec nous sur arte france
[Musique]
c'est une image que mister justement
vous allez taxer les autres résultats on
a vu cette délicate et route
si je lui dis je t'offre caniche ses
méthodes
a dakar on suppose m'accroche au marché
non domestique ou baguette par contre un
agent de l'état belge d'une troupe des
process la torre du jeu de sony mytischi
dj et idh2 which have on a dit reid
ashton eaton garde à vue d'esprit
résultat 3
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes à chier boxart y allons
faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à ba là on est
alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière fois celle en profiter
en 2011 et ne demande pas un petit peu
non ah oui et c'est tous les fromages
tous les soucis sont toutes les les
croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylée
les français ne savent pas je ne pensais
jamais de ma vie faire la plonge
autonomie vous pouvez me souhaiter bon
courage
à très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
je
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview avec comme invité
cette semaine une personnalité qui se
fait très discrète c'est claudie
haigneré
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté cette
invitation vous êtes installé chez vous
afin de respecter les conditions
sanitaires le coronavirus nous impose
vous avez été astronautes et je suis sûr
que beaucoup de gens s'en souviennent de
vol dans l'espace
comment vivez vous cette période de
confinement qui nous oblige finalement
être dispensés dans ce sens ce climat
général qui est quand même
il reste très anxiogène bonjour vraiment
ravi de pouvoir passer ce moment avec
vous c'est vrai que je re préféré être
plus proche de vous et c'est vrai que ce
qui peut être limite beaucoup c'est
cette possibilité de se déplacer d'avoir
des contacts et de d'entrer davantage
dans dans les champs dans la vraie
relation humaine et c'est peut-être ce
qui me ce qui me manque aujourd'hui
c'est ce que j'ai eu la chance de vivre
dans une aventure humaine effectivement
extraordinaire d'avoir les ce privilège
de faire deux missions spatiales avec
des coéquipiers des collègues des
équipes et on était vraiment dans cet
échange présentiel même si une fois dans
la station spatiale on est à distance
effectivement à 400 km en orbite autour
de la terre c'est vraiment un travail
d'équipé avec à la fois l'équipage et
puis toutes les équipes qui se bat aux
côtés donc ce manque d'interaction c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas gênante
c'est vrai alors c'est ce parcours
auquel vous faites allusion
cette expérience cette expertise aussi
que que vous avez qui fait que nous
avons de votre part beaucoup de choses à
apprendre sur la situation que nous
vivons actuellement on a plein de
raisons d'avoir envie de vous écouter je
disais en vous accueillant que vous êtes
une des rares femmes spationautes ou
astronaute je ne sais pas ce qu'on dit
on dit astronautes 1 vous avez effectué
le disait un premier vol dans l'espace
de seize jours c'était à bord de la
station mir c'était en 1904
20 16 corrigez moi si je me trompe mais
c'était au mois d'août et dans le cadre
d'une mission franco russe
après vous êtes allez vous entraînez
vous êtes resté à la cité des étoiles à
la base spatiale de de la russie puis en
janvier 2001 vous serez la première
femme à voler à bord de la station
internationale iss
alors vous savez que l parlant c'était
en octobre à 2001 il n'entend rien
c'était en octobre 2001 j'ai donc merci
de me merci de me corriger mais vous
savez que ce bois 6 1 puisque nous
sommes en avril aura lieu le